good morning John I'm using tripod for
support so I don't fall over
oh goodness jet lag is real I was
staying in a very nice hotel in
Melbourne part of the Pan Pacific Hotel
chain you ever stated of Pan Pacific
they're so nice beautiful view out over
the river soft satin sheets I don't know
what satin is probably they were cotton
but nice cotton cotton that grew out of
the ground with one hope in its little
cotton brain to make me happy Melbourne
was super nice the whole experience of
VidCon Australia was so nice I love
Australians it was so great but John
back to this hotel for a second there
was a bath tub and a shower like this
was a nice place the art and I'm sorry I
didn't take any video what do you expect
what am i a professional video I am I am
here's the toilet paper was a miserable
disgrace I get that if I'm like at
Walmart and I have to poo that I'm gonna
be touching my butt with the worst thing
ever
I'm not happy about it but that's the
sitch it's Walmart I used to work at
Walmart
people like would go in and take all of
the toilet paper off the Roll with them
home I replace the toilet paper rolls
and I knew that like okay it's been two
hours somebody filled their backpack
with the Walmart toilet paper and they
left okay that's a way to save some
money that I had not thought of that's
why Walmart doesn't have nice to their
paper because people will take it but
this was a very nice hotel Australians
just have like iron but raise your hand
if you had got a like a but problem I
just want you to know that you're not
the only one a lot of people just raise
their hands there are a lot of blood
problems I don't think that we should be
ashamed of them there's hemorrhoids
there's anal fissures you don't want to
be ashamed of that one but you also
don't really want to say it out loud and
so many people have IBD like the more
you go to the bathroom
the more chance of just pant area
unpleasantness you got to get clean uh
we don't have bidets cuz it's America in
Europe they got but days four days is
something I say and I think maybe a lot
of people who don't have butt problems
aren't aware that that can be the worst
a single bad toilet paper experience can
ruin like days of my life like walking
becomes a thing that I like I don't want
to do that and I've developed some
techniques and strategies
good to have like a like a little tube
of I don't know basically diaper rash
cream little lubrication free this is
your butt cheeks right here and so your
cheeks your booty is what cheeks get
some bee into your linen make an
appointment and then the irritation that
you strut sheets your butt cheeks
these hands are your butt cheeks the
motion are making this a simulation of
the action about the your butt cheek
these are your butt cheeks maybe I
should go the next step and I should
take my like ultra soft downy or
whatever with the bears that they're so
happy about how the butts are very clean
whatever those bears are I basically buy
toilet paper the opposite of how I order
food when I'm at a restaurant I open the
menu and I'm like this is too much and I
just picked the cheapest thing the
toilet paper is the opposite of that I
just buy the most expensive toilet paper
because I assume that they've done
something is confusing though right
because sometimes like double the length
of roll and yeah man I don't know I
don't know give me like a per yard cause
you're making it intentionally confusing
I I understand that's how profit work
step one make a product step to confuse
the consumer step three profit I get it
it works for the American Medical system
you guys gonna have to get some Sal for
that burn which you will charge
yourselves way too much for anyway I
understand that it's capitalism in our
home lives we don't see the 20% or 40%
premium that we're paying for a nicer
toilet paper at a business especially
one that buys a lot of toilet paper is
gonna see that as a huge and important
expense that they're gonna want to
eliminate the cost of people with but
problems having a good day John I will
see you on Tuesday